[Music]
leave your memes on
let's just get it out of the way let's
just leave whatever you comment you
gotta say
i've accepted it it's fine let's just
get into the memes
we get past this oh no
[Laughter]
102 000
this is not my top voted of all time
please not the wedding photo
not the wedding oh thank god okay okay
all right
you hear that this one's your eagle
uh nordvpn sponsor
you're browsing the internet unprotected
sorry that was gross but not as gross as
not going to nordvpn.com
pewdiepie take control of your internet
experience
today get access to anywhere across the
world
with nordvpn and right now is a great
time to sign up for nordvpn because
you like surprises oh yeah there's a
special cyber deal
cyber deal cyber deal cyber deal every
purchase get this
with a two-year plan get this
one additional month for free
but get this okay you also get
a surprise gift go to nordvpn.com
pewdiepie
pewdiepie pewdiepie people use pewdiepie
at checkout
it's risk free they have a 30 day money
back guarantee what you got to lose
special gift can't lose it if you sign
up get the deal before it's too late
thank you norvik fan for sponsoring this
video
sponsor eagle
wow thank you uh ksi for that wonderful
bro kissed me hard that looks so good
he's already got the eternian all
powerful i guess i gotta give him the
award huh
god damn it what's the highest one i can
do
peepee oh there's a hundred bucks
oh there it is 50 000
it's 200 bucks are you serious
why didn't i get that money did i
miscalculate
all right it's only fair that this
beautiful art there you go
gets recognized there you go ksi you've
you've earned it
you made it a grand of this reddit post
what the [ __ ]
i gotta do this again all right let's
see him
i would do my own oh my god he did his
own
what is this trash are you serious
this always is so powerful and whoever
this is
deserves to be a moderator yes what's
going on
come on mind me questions this is trash
i don't even have a mustache like that
how's this present
i i don't i don't why would
and this took you 240 000 hours you're
not
find a new hobby mate because this ain't
it i'm so confused
and then what we go down to the next
post
and it's 29 000.
oh something's happened am i being
trolled wait did he not realize
oh my god well [ __ ] hell we really
pewdiepie drew jj he's got a little bit
of that handsome squidward vibe to him
i'll give him that
anyone want to see it oh yeah
i'm sorry ksi please give me money yeah
it's gotta look good
it's not gonna give me money okay cool
the chain is becoming a little bit like
uh it worked it worked
for this i like that maybe we'll do like
a crossover dude he could totally
he's got the bandana he's got the chain
if kesai doesn't dress up
as i'm abdul on halloween i'll be
disappointed that's all i'm gonna say
huge shoulders huge breastsicles
tiny nipples the pinnacle of man will do
the jojo
signs because they look like a jj so he
makes perfect
oh what a marvelous piece of art
[Laughter]
let's go let's
one of the go pieces of art i have ever
seen
thank you thank you i knew he would like
it
so much okay
hey i got the alternian i'm happy what
is this
furby pie oh great what the [ __ ]
why would you do that oh my god
oh you got to use my eyes there you go
nice
cute it's like watching one of my old
photoshop videos
hey that's great well done
belongs in the museum what do you think
come you like it
i don't play with dolls i'm an adult
thank you i'm a sheriff now
feel american with this mustache
that's my american impression thank you
after watching pete's workout video
i was inspired to follow it too but i
was too lazy and then had time
this is a cool stuff
damn well done what a massive change
right there
inspiring incredible thanks pewds such
an inspiration
incredible just put the time in what are
you gonna do
look at memes all day you [ __ ] loser
hey pewds
your account got hacked oh yeah i saw
this don't worry
i got it back me playing and uploading
every single one i saw because i enjoyed
it people who posted the video on
something
[Music]
it's my cover remember this kid he was
in peers video
oh yeah of course we'll remember you
kiddo
we'll never forget bro fists from me oh
the crtx on well done it looks
just like me um thanks for that nose
he forgot the stash i've always had this
always i feel like i should be
committing war crimes or something
this is the stash that does it just me
okay hell yeah mother nature be like
oh you're doing no nut no no well how
about the
four days what is it day eight
i know exactly exactly what day it is
i'm counting every single month
oh dude my gaming skills have improved
at least 12 my nails
way stronger i can crawl on walls
very soon my musical talents have
improved
vastly as you can tell g-fuel
tastes better come on you can still hop
on no no let's go
[Music]
stop i don't look like ned flanders
i look like a badass sheriff god damn it
see this is mid-shave all right i i'm
not supposed to
god damn it look it looks better now
tell me it looks good yeah i can buy
anything in the world except
true priceless it's okay i love you mr
beast don't worry
don't worry art contest hell yeah
that's great big peepee right there boys
have only four moons
acting like a gangster chilling with the
no all right
it's been two years guys two years i've
been a good boy
all right no oopsies can we appreciate
that
you know how hard i'm just kidding
president mississippi
joe jergensen joe joe jurgen
next meme what are you proud of dude i
once managed to get into hawaii with
only 200 upvotes [ __ ] legend
that's impossible you need at least
twenty thousand get the [ __ ] out of here
mate felix that's a pokemon card hell
yeah
oh that's sick dope
i like it got the holographics cool
when his fans start bullying his new
look case i
first time there's nothing to bully here
all right i'm the bully
you can't bully the bully now go back to
bed
oh god damn it that's really cool
i like it
[Laughter]
yo that mad light did it
hell yeah that's a tambourine stroking
stroke a tambourine stroke sorry
and respect arthur shelby this is my
favorite oh yeah here we go all right
i i don't even know who this is i look
nothing like him
i look more threatening hey pull down
your pants
i'm not [ __ ] around sad is that is
that more threatening
i feel like it makes it more threatening
i i find myself keep
nodding to other men with mustache that
i see on the street now like yeah
you got a mustache i got a mustache
and then i forget i live in the gay
capital of ukraine
pewdiepie versus ksi we want morpheus
versus doggy wait he's got a hamster
hell yeah i agree they need to battle we
need to know what superior pay
mine up of course hey you're looking ned
flynn i don't
[Laughter]
you're not allowed to put it in a video
shape
that's a great meme template
live footage of pewdiepie when martial
doesn't check
what a little [ __ ] i got a mustache now
i would never cry
and if i did the mustache would suck up
the tears
go right back into my system oh god
no
god damn it [ __ ] you grease ball
[ __ ] you ah kind of handsome though ah
real life anime there it is well done
casey
that's the best fan art i've ever seen
on this reddit thank you for
helping us peek
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey kid you want some g fuel i got you
come here come over here in the alleyway
pulls that
threatening knife
i already did it nobody that baby's
staring at me on the bus
oh i remember this reminds me one time
when i was uh
really young a baby kept staring at me
so i stared back at it
and i made like weird threatening faces
because i thought it was funny
like i don't remember what kind of face
i made but i was kind of taunting the
baby for
staring at me and then i look to the
left of the baby and i see the dad just
staring blankly at me with a
blank face like what the [ __ ] are you
doing
top top five most awkward moment of my
life very good
thank you thank you babies you're
useless
every time i tell mark said that she
doesn't do this i always catch her doing
it
what do you mean i don't do it what do
you mean
[Laughter]
[Music]
his teacher wiped his ass calm he broke
his ass panic
i'll give an ass update very soon i
actually have a lot up there it's not
gonna
it's not even a meme sadly not all
dressed up for school ball
looking like a baller hell yeah big
peepee energy
that's it right there well done
pewdiepie when he gets a new mic
[Music]
correct pewdiepie with a knife me
pewdiepie would mustache me
pity myself
oh my god what you guys do this
that's never happened to me
[Laughter]
we need fat ksi and fat pewdiepie collab
come on guys can we make it happen
please
hell yeah dudes how does pointless get
his hair like that it's literally
possible because i
what the [ __ ] dude god damn it feels
gonna be salty yeah
shut up you don't know me but yeah all
right
okay all right all right
okay all right
all right coco melon intros have
officially peaked congratulations guys
all right
thanks pewds i had been going to the gym
for eight months and so you encouraged
people to work out so i started eating
10k calories a day
because i'm not a [ __ ] simp i
do what you want all right i added your
control of your own life
great coming right
[Laughter]
kid can we have doctor disrespect
no we already have doctor disrespected
home all right no
i'm not budget come on come on come on
peter's waiting for his kindergarten
t-shirt to wipe his hands
hey it's got that it looks just like me
it looks
should i get a ball haircut next should
we get it bring it back
it's time isn't it what the [ __ ] is that
what'd anime say
no seven deadly sins all right i started
watching that
and then i realized i'm 30 and i stopped
watching also felix watch his avatar all
right shut up
felix shelby before following
pewdiepie's workout tutorial
felix shelburg after following see it
worked for me
all right you can do it too pure g fuel
diet
as a joke just to be clear all right i
never turn ad blocks on your channel
because your channel never has ads on it
great thanks guys same vibe
same vibe
this is where he falls off the bed
i remember this being really funny
[Laughter]
oh my god he's fine the dog is fine
he protect he attack but most
importantly
he fall on the back there's one of maya
too
pug falling off bed but i like that they
don't even know it's my dog
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh it's not funny if it happens to mine
it is better to get in the shower than
shower in the true
i've actually taken a shoe in the shower
once it's a long story
but uh someone poisoned me okay i swear
to god
someone poisoned me all the toilets were
occupied there was a long line
i said it's an emergency
but all the doors were locked so i
rushed in the building
i looked everywhere and then i finally
found the door that had a lock on it
so i i i was like all right bingo thank
god because it's coming whether i want
it or not
i opened the door with the light
thinking i made it
all sweaty from trying to hold in this
demon
inside of me and then i open the door
and i see it's not a toilet it's a
shower
and at that point i had no choice i had
to do what i had to do
and that's the story how i shipped in
the shower
it was actually at my job and i didn't
clean it up
and all the employees the day after told
of the horror story
of how they had to clean up the ship by
some [ __ ]
who sat in the shower
i'm sorry okay i'm sorry
i'm sorry i was too embarrassed i had to
eat
other people came in looking for toilets
too i'm not gonna go oh
i should be in the shower hold up guys
let me clean it up i took off all right
i panicked i would have cleaned it up by
the way i'm sorry
it happens it happens to all of us felix
shaves his beard and keeps his mustache
should bring awareness to prostate
cancer
men's health and suicide prevention is
bad
that's right everyone for this month of
november
i'm keeping a mustache to support
november which is a charity group
that brings awareness to prostate cancer
men's health and suicide prevention
we're also donating all the member
revenue that we got from this month
which was i think
140 8 000
which is epic thank you guys for being
members on this channel i really
appreciate it it's really cool to
support charities this month that is a
great cause
join me join me and you can nodded other
fellow men with mustaches
or women women can mustache too i ain't
hating
me imagining myself as a badass anime
belly god damn it
i just want to look what corpse sounds
like is that too much to ask
and on that note we're ending this video
here thanks for watching guys
subscribe look at the graph it's free
thanks for watching brofist
[Music]